كنا عم نتحدث عن انه التحولات في العالم
طبعا يعني تفرض لغه شاعريه موازيه ولكن
ايضا مثل ما ذكرت الذهاب الى لغات اخرى
الى اللغه الاخرى التي يكتب فيها الشعر
غير العربيه ايضا تجعل الكاتب او الشاعر
ينتبه الى موضوعات او الى الى لغه اخرى
يعني قمت بمقاربه بينك يعني بين النص
الشعري العربي بشكل عام عم بحكي وبين النص
الذي يكتب بلغات اخرى اللي هو بالاسبانيه
او بالفرنسيه او بالانجليزيه في ميزان في
ميزان وضعته لتشوف هناك هناك بعض
الملاحظات في نظري مهمه في الاونه الاخيره
صدر كتاب في الاندلس يجمع بين شعراء
مغاربه وشعراء اندلسيين اندولوجيا
والمغربي هناك تجارب الاسبانيه مترجمه الى
العربيه والتجارب المغربيه مترجمه الى
الاسبانيه
من يقرا القصائد سيلاحظ
بسهوله ان هناك التقاء في عدد من المواضيع
ولكن هناك
تباين كبير في اساليب التعبير وفي الجمله
الشعريه وفي الرؤيه الشريعه كذلك جميل
واطلاعي على هذا النوع من
الانتيولوجيات يجعلني افكر بان الشعر يجب
ان لا يعيش في قاعه مغلقه وفي ولا تخنقه
لغته يجب ان يتغذى من لغات اخرى ومن
ترجمات ومن لان هذا هو الذي يمكن ان يؤسس
لحوار بين شعريات مختلفه كثير من اللغات
مثلا طورت
التعبيرات مرتبطه
بقضايا معينه او بمواضيع معينه هناك لقاء
مثلا مستمر بين الفلسفه والشعر في الشعر
الالماني هناك لقاء عميق بين الطبيعه
والشعر في الشعر الياباني هناك
علاقه قويه مع البحر
والمجهول البحر في الشعر البرتغالي لدينا
لدينا ايضا شيء من هذا ولكن
ربما نحن ما يميزنا هو الارتباط
بالتعبير البلاغي اكثر من من هذه
الاهتمامات الاخرى
ولذلك نحتاج الى خروج من من هذا النفق
البلاغي نحتاج الى الخروج منه اللغه
العربيه لها قدرات خارقه على تكيف وعلى
وعلى التحول في اشتقاقات ولكن الشعر ليس
مساله لغويه فحسف تماما ولهذا يجب ان نخرج
كذلك من من غول اللغه نحن نكتب باللغه لها
هيمنه
علينا ويجب ان نتحرم فيها شيء من القدسيه
يعني